space discoveries are some of the
greatest achievements our civilization
rightfully takes pride in
and today still more fascinating
scientific prospects are looming up
ahead
but what if all these processes are
doomed
destined to be stopped by the greatest
threat to our species
and sooner or later the depths of the
universe will reveal to mankind
irrefutable evidence of what ultimate
fate has in store for any living
creature
namely the inevitability of death
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
according to the theory we'll be looking
at today
any intelligent race is bound to face a
number of insurmountable obstacles at a
certain stage of its development
and the upshot of the development of any
civilization
is that sooner or later it is to meet
its demise
with no traces or evidence of its
existence left behind
the hypothesis we'll be talking about is
called the great filter
to estimate the plausibility of such
prospects we will have to direct our
gaze into the future
and to speculate about issues likely to
be lying in weight ahead of us that
we're going to encounter while evolving
as a species
the idea of the great filter hypothesis
was first put forward by the economist
robin hansen in 1996.
the theory was supposed to account for
the fermi paradox
something i told you about in one of our
earlier videos
according to the author says there are
no traces of extraterrestrial
civilizations to be seen in the
observable part of the universe
it is doubtful the chances of the birth
of intelligent life forms are high
and so arguments in favor of this motion
have to be seriously questioned
it is feasible that factors as yet
unknown to science may
impede the evolution of life forms not
allowing them to grow into a
civilization advanced enough to venture
into the cosmos
and become a galactic race if the
hypothesis were to be believed
such like factors may well get in the
way of our species too
as for the notion of the great filter
itself it specifies what some of these
obstacles may be like
chronologically they can be either in
the past when animals are prevented from
evolving to become intelligent species
or in the future meaning that there is a
big hazard of an intelligent
civilization
almost certainly finding itself on the
road to self-destruction
in our case the concept implies that the
easier the evolution has occurred until
now
the worse the prospects for humankind
appear to be for the future
in other words if we still haven't had
to deal with our great filter
it is highly likely we will yet have to
do so at some point
initially the hypothesis was met with
skepticism
the evolution of species on our planet
has been going on rather smoothly
which means that there may well be or
may have been for that matter
similar conditions elsewhere in the
universe
in addition to that the drake equation
shows that in the milky way alone there
should be at least
several dozen advanced civilizations
at least some of them are bound to have
got the hang of radio astronomy
or constructed spacecraft like our
voyages
consequently interaction with an alien
civilization
cannot be that elusive however
ever since we set out on our search for
other intelligent races out there
the universe hasn't dropped as much as a
single hint of anybody else dwelling in
its vast expanses
the hypothetical great filter may well
be the reason for this lack of clues
the hypothesis suggests that the role of
the great filter may be played by one or
several obstacles an advanced
civilization has to power through in the
course of its evolution
if a filter of this sort does exist that
should explain why we still haven't
received any signals from advanced
civilizations from elsewhere in the
universe
incidentally the hypothesis admits of
the possibility of some creatures
surviving the great filter
to do it successfully they have to
complete several stages
to begin with their planet has to be in
the goldilocks zone of its parent star
next life has to originate and start
evolving there
with the organisms capable of
multiplying using molecules like dna
and rna after that
single cells have to evolve into more
complex ones
while the evolution of multicellular
organisms will be vigorously stimulated
this in its turn should stimulate the
development of sexual propagation which
will be good for genetic diversity
eventually this will produce yet more
elaborate organisms capable of using
tools for developing to the level of
advanced enough technologies
necessary for space colonization
they will then proceed to colonize other
worlds and stellar systems
to ensure survival and obviate the
eventuality of self-destruction
robin hansen argues that it is then and
only then that the great filter will
become a thing of the past
within this concept at the current stage
of evolution
mankind should be bracing up for the
most challenging one coming next
when other celestial bodies are going to
have to be colonized for the human race
to survive
however it is hardly necessary to point
out that the plaur's
of going through with this plan is
rather small
robin hansen maintained that there is a
fatal obstacle that an intelligent
species
encounters at some of the nine steps of
its evolution
this is supposed to be something
definitive that causes
total elimination of the species
mankind may have completed eight steps
of evolution
the chances of successfully completing
the ninth are rather slim
and that last step may prove to be that
very fatal obstacle
a number of other points are set out in
the hypothesis
for example it specifies measures that
must be taken by civilization to
eliminate the risk of self-destruction
as a result of internal wars
irreversibly detrimental impacts on
ecology and the depletion of natural
resources
apart from the exclusively theoretical
benefits offered by this reasoning
it could be really useful for working
out our strategies for space exploration
from the perspective of the great filter
theory proponents
the discovery of extinct multicellular
life forms on mars
should be bad news it will imply that
most of the steps we have completed so
far have been comparatively easy
and so the greatest challenge will be
posed by the steps still lying ahead of
us
that is why the easier hypothetical
evolution occurred on other planets
the higher the probability that mankind
will never grow to be a space-faring
civilization
but actually it isn't all doom and gloom
for all we know we may have already
negotiated our toughest obstacle at one
of the steps already completed
for this reason some researchers believe
that the fact that we appear to be alone
in the universe is actually a good sign
this could indicate that we're the lucky
few who have passed through the great
filter
quite unscathed still we can't but admit
that people use only several forms of
communication
whereas there may be considerably more
of them
either way the universe is estimated to
have existed for 13.8
billion years and there may well be a
great number of organisms out there
that would have overcome these obstacles
but hardly any of them will learn that
they're not the only ones around
for this they have to accomplish a major
technological breakthrough
which in theory is to be their undoing
and lead to a global apocalypse
the situation on our planet demonstrates
just that
we're able to eliminate the entire human
race as a result of a global
thermonuclear war the odds are rather
high that our civilization will be wiped
off the face of the earth before
either super powerful engines or more
effective forms of communication have
been developed
it is also hard to actually identify the
great filter
as the environment on other planets may
be completely different from ours
for instance abiogenesis a process of
inorganic nature transforming into
organic one
is bizarre and fascinating and it may
actually be the great filter for many
intelligent races
given all this the great filter
hypothesis prompts a number of important
questions
is mankind going to be able to
adequately and successfully respond to
an unexpected challenge
or is the worst already in the past and
the silence of the universe is a sign
that we are one of the few races to have
completed all the stages devised by the
great filter
unfortunately we cannot answer any of
this today
and the only thing we can do now is to
brace up for a trial the universe has in
store for us
whatever it may be
you